we are still hearing some new rather
shocking allegations following the death
of long time zappo ceo tony shea a
longtime friend is suing for a piece of
his estate claiming a family member
fueled shea's addiction to drugs now the
i-team first alerted you to this inside
the eight news now app our own david
charns covering the shake case from the
beginning live in studio now david brian
denise lawyers for this friend alleged
shea's brother provided him with
canisters of nitrous oxide you may have
heard them called whippets as well as
alcohol in his final years this is all
happening as the two sides battle for
pieces of the late entrepreneur's nearly
billion dollar estate
court documents filed in response to
claims tony shea's friends took
advantage of him painting a different
picture quote it was andy shea that
plied tony shea with alcohol during mr
shea's final months the allegation about
tony shea's brother andrew from tony lee
a man who describes himself as a
longtime friend of the late zappos ceo
previous court documents from shea's
family say tony shea was addicted to
nitrous oxide or whippets canisters
filled with laughing gas quote it was
andy that arranged for the purchase of
thousands of canisters of nitrous oxide
at an alarming rate for tony shea's
continued use when others who cared for
mr shea refused to do so previous
documents say tony shea used as many as
50 cartridges of nitrous oxide a day the
documents are part of the lawsuit to
divvy up shea's enormous wealth which
lee says he's entitled to seven million
dollars of
the parties involved have asked for
hearings in these cases lawyers have
meaning this will all continue to play
out in public possibly in a courtroom
next month no one responded to our
request for comment today brian